[Musique]
bon françois truffaut vous nous avez
écouté et là dans un petit coin ça vous
fait quel effet de n'entendre les
critiques par les deux films comme ça
forcément vite trop vite bien sûr mais
il y en a beaucoup
là on va avoir un peu de temps pour vous
quand même dit ce que vous en pensez
ça vous paraît comment ça vous paraît
bien utile faites nous des critiques de
toute façon je vous écoute le dimanche
enfin presque tous les dimanches ça vous
regarde le film de la première est
vraiment extraordinaire
mais moi je trouve que c'est comment
dirais-je
je préfère parler entendre parler du
cinéma à la radio qu'à la télévision je
trouve que les mots donne plus envie de
voir des images que des images donnerait
envie de voir d'autres humains on est
trop souvent le cinéma est défraîchi et
par les extraits de films comme on
traite et vision et même quelquefois au
cinéma même par la bande annonce je ne
sais même pas si le système la
bande-annonce est bon bonjour moi ce qui
donne envie de voir un film c'est d'en
entendre parler ou de regarder les
photos devant la salle donc je trouve
que votre émission vraiment je le dis à
d'autres occasions c'est pas parce que
je suis là donne envie de voir les films
bien alors pour l'animer trop mal
georges visite puisque avant par les
derniers pays métro puisque vous êtes
engagés sur le terrain de la critique
est ce que tu m'autoriserai a rappelé
que françois truffaut a été critique de
cinéma et d'art et qu'il a joué un rôle
d'une importance capitale
oui réussi à part la balance en sait
trop quand même
il a joué un rôle d'une importance
capitale en interdisant l'accès à
l'écran de la plupart de ses grands
aînés pour prendre leur place
alors je voudrais quand même ah bon je
voudrais quand même lui demander quand
il se retourne vers son passé ce qu'il
pense des partis pris car il faut bien
nourrir des parties de prix qu'il a pris
dans il ya une vingtaine d'années à
l'époque où il tenait cette rubrique
dans un
des noms des noms moi je joue mais les
noms dans une veine ouest claude autant
lara qui n'a pratiquement plus tourner
après les descentes en flammes de
truffaut non mais non au sens où la
question de charensol légitime autant je
trouve que la destination qu'il en donne
est exagéré parce que c'est pallier ce
ne peut pas être innocent qui ont pécho
n'a retourné les cahiers du cinéma dont
il était un des collaborateurs et tous
ses camarades ont fait des tirs de
barrage
mais ils ont surtout fait des films ils
ont enlevé des villes des préfets
excusez moi ont fait des tirs de barrage
sur leurs aînés et le fait est là ses
aînés ont quitté la scène et l'écran
bien entendu non et il est si jeune
aurier c'est un fait
est ce son et c'est là et c'est la bande
des cahiers place aux jeunes qui a pris
leur place
le ce sont les faits sont là c'est même
pas effectivement nous étions des
critiques assez véhément éventuellement
péremptoire éventuellement oui oui
violent mais je crois que dans le
souvenir que dans le souvenir on
privilégie toujours les articles contre
enfin les articles compte de toute façon
on plus de brio ou restent davantage
dans les mémoires mais il me semble si
nous étions des critiques militants nous
étions militants dans les deux sens
c'est à dire que je me souviens très
bien le noël ou est sorti lola montès
qui était escompté par tous les
critiques de quotidiens et aussi par le
public et bien là c'est deux trois
quatre articles que nous faisions et on
allait voir le film 4 5 fois la semaine
dire l'enthousiasmé il était dans les
deux sens j'étais enthousiaste pour
démolir un film comme le ballon rouge
que je ne mets pas bon peut-être que
j'avais tort mais je ne vais pas filmé
puis j'étais enthousiaste pour défendre
tel films de cocteau d'ophuls ou deux je
crois pas que ce soit ce n'était pas un
règlement de comptes entre générations
comme vous le laisser supposer voyez
c'était l'impression vos deniers nous
donnions nous disions tout le temps
qu'il était injuste par exemple que
roger leenhardt ne fasse pas d'autre
film nous souhaitions d'autres films de
cocteau d'autres fine d'ophuls tati et
bresson aussi était complètement l'année
du condamné à mort s'est échappé d'un
goûter
moi je dis rue renoir bien sûr je dirais
que l'année 57 et bien il n'y a
franchement pas eu beaucoup de films
français intéressant en dehors du
condamné à mort s'est échappé vous me
regardez si vous vous rappelez vous même
je crois que vous faites partie du jury
du prix delluc
rappelez vous que dans ces années là
vous
vous étiez très embarrassé de donner le
prix delluc ses textes à une année vous
l'avez donné un court métrage une autre
année vous l'avez donné aux casses pieds
de noël noël jean dréville il n'y avait
pas le choix qu'il ya aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on dit du mal du sénat
français mais quand même à la fin de
l'année vous avez des films pour
lesquels voter aux césars ou de lui dans
les prix ça n'existait pas à ce moment
là j'avais aussi il paraît que vous avez
défendu un film de claude autant-lara
sur l'occupation quitté d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus inconfortable que le veau
par rapport à cette période qui mettait
dans le public dans un grand palais ce
qu'était la traverse est par exemple les
chances sont meilleures suivre sur les
français sont d'ailleurs faits mais
aussi en cas de malheur d'après simenon
que j'aimais beaucoup mais je n'ai pas
changé de position sur le rouge et le
noir et je dirais la manière de lubitsch
qu'avec le rouge et le noir il avait
fait à stendhal ce que les nazis ont
fait à la pologne
c'est bien ce que je suis de cet avis
aussi tient alors même quand je revois
le diable au corps at et visions les
mêmes choses m'ont gêné au même endroit
les mêmes répliques la même façon de
valoriser le couple principal est de
reculer de ridiculiser personnages
secondaires sont ces reproches là qu'on
faisait à cette forme de cinéma et il se
trouve enfin quand je revois les vieux
films la télévision je retrouve les
mêmes
oui je suis fâché au même endroit pour
les mêmes raisons à peu près bien pour
les rôles secondaires dans le dernier
métro au contraire on sent que vous les
aimez vous n'avez pas fait un film sur
un couple sait moins c'est une question
d'égalité de regard je crois c'est à
dire qu autrefois je ne sais pas
pourquoi dans cette toute cette série-là
du sénat français ont parlé il y avait
l'idée qu'il fallait garder le couple
principal prestigieux je ne comprends
pas pourquoi parce qu'on peut très bien
rire dans le cinéma américain on nous
fait souvent rire avec l'héroïne pour
évidemment qu'on a derrière les seconds
rôles comiques qui sont là enfin il
s'agit de ne pas faire de différence de
traitements effectivement dans le regard
qu faut quelqu'un se dévoue pour dire en
deux mots ce que c'est que le dernier
métro pour ceux qui par hasard ne le
sauraient pas non qui veut faire ça qui
va me faire le petit
ou alors cette rumeur c'est une
évocation du théâtre pendant
l'occupation du terrain parisien pendant
le pendant l'occupation attentes et le
titre s'explique par le fait que
à l'époque du couvre feu on est obligé
de rentrer chez soi par le dernier métro
et tous les spectacles et toute la vie
finalement de la capitale étaient réglés
sur ce dernier métro qu'il fallait
absolument pas rater ce en quoi on
saisit coffret par les allemands alors
c'est donc l'histoire d'une pièce qui
est créé dans un petit théâtre parisien
est créé avec de plus de très grandes
difficultés puisque le directeur du
théâtre qui est juif à une interdiction
pratiquement d'exercer et que cacher
dans son angle sous sol de son théâtre
alors il a fait croire qu'il a quitté la
france il continue à mettre en scène et
à produire la pièce qui se joue par à
conseiller la mise en scène voilà
finalement il dirige tout est d'ailleurs
ils voient tous vos lits pratiquement et
il est le personnage invisible et
catherine deneuve et la dirigeante en
tout est là catherine et katherine
relève la directrice officielle du du
théâtre voilà en gros voilà l'intrigant
de 1 2 posté à peu près ça si on veut
être si on fait ça mais en mêlant va
être un petit peu moins sommaire et vous
allez peut-être dire ce que vous en
pensez les uns les autres qui veut qui
doit en parler voilà c'est un film que
j'aime infiniment et je n'hésite pas à
dire en présence de françois truffaut
que à mes yeux c'est son meilleur film
avec adèle h et je trouve qu'il y à là
cette extraordinaire intelligence
doublée d'une très grande sensibilité il
a parfaitement compris qu'il ne fallait
pas comme l'ont fait tant d'autres
prendre l'occupation de faux il a pris
par un biais très intelligent qui est
celui du théâtre donc un mélange
constant de rêve et de réalité puisqu'il
ya certes un seul spectateur qui est
dans la salle ne sait pas si les deux
acteurs dialogue vraiment autres acteurs
ou entre hommes et femmes
et ce n'est que quand la caméra avance
ou recule quand on s'aperçoit que c'est
du théâtre ou que c'est de la vie je
cite cet exemple pour montrer à quel
point le théâtre et la vie sont
imbriqués dans son film de plus il l'a
ménagé un très grand nombre de scènes
drôles de 2 je ne dirais pas de gamme
car il n'y a pas de gagnant faire de
tout même de scènes de comédie qui
montre que l'occupation n'a pas été pour
constamment ce temps faire quel a été
pour beaucoup mais pas pour tout le
monde et en particulier pour les gens de
théâtre karl steiner qui a passé quatre
ans dans la cave de son théâtre quand
même à côté de lui un énorme jambon et
bien moi je veux dire j'ai passé cinq
ans dans le midi de la france n'est
jamais mis les pieds à paris pendant
l'occupation mais j'ai jamais vu de
jambon non plus bon alors
donc je ne peux pas juger de
l'atmosphère du paris jean-pierre
semblables je ne peux pas juger du pari
de que pas sûr puisque je n'y étais pas
mais tous ceux qui ont vécu cette époque
là et qui m'ont parlé du film de
truffaut me disent c'est exactement ça
il à recréer cette atmosphère
extrêmement extrêmement troublée
extrêmement complexe monsieur qu'affirme
son occupation non mais c'est maintenant
fait c'est très très important qui n'est
pas pro de claudine et la wiimote et à
paris pendant toute l'occupation oui je
dois dire que c'est le premier film que
je vois et qui est vraiment qui recrée
l'atmosphère exact de l'époque je n'ai
été choqués par rien que par les tout
petits détails
musculeux l'essentiel est exactement
flottaison pied qui porte l'étoile juive
à ça le pompier qui portait de gilet sur
mon vrai pas attendu la vente est un peu
trop ils étaient 25 dans paris 25
pompiers juives qui ont pu continuer
leur métier parce qu'ils s'étaient
reconnus d'utilité publique
le colonel a fait une démarche à la
préfecture de police pour être dispensé
l'étoile jaune et on a dit non ils
doivent la porter mais enfin ils ont le
droit d'exercer leur métier
de même que vous publiez est médecin il
y avait en principe l'interdiction des
métiers et professions libérales
sauf quelques unes reconnue d'utilité
publique donc on ne pouvait pas jouer
normalement vous pouvez pas jouer sur
scène dans un film si on était juif
enfin ce portrait juive de théâtre à
exister aurait exactement dans ce film
c'est le l'anti jeu enfin le côté anti
allemand du peuple français dans ça
parce que il y avait beaucoup de
collaborateurs beaucoup d'attentisme
dans la bourgeoisie mais le peuple était
vraiment anti allemand dans sa gueule et
or par exemple la dame quand un officier
et un soldat allemand passe et tout cela
les cheveux d'un petit garçon va lui
laver la tête après dont l'excès de la
chose sa réponse c'est une traduction
exacte des sentiments du peuple français
c'est petit c'est énorme et ça c'est
c'est bon alors il ya dans ce film yann
il ya des collaborateurs et dieu sait
puisqu'on voit alain lowbrow de je suis
partout qui est admirablement joué
fantasma richard je les croisais et
admire mais jamais rencontré alain
l'aube rouge je les croise ayant dans la
rue ça va feindre au défilé parmi les
acquis le livre bleu admirable il ya des
résistances puisque depardieu et
résistant et puis à laurière même cet
immense majorité de gens ce qu'ils
étaient la plupart ans qui allemand mais
qui continuait de vivre et de travailler
il fallait bien c'était ça la vie et
françois fall a recréé admirablement est
alors avec aussi dans le décor
ennemi de paris c'était sale et bon côté
au jambon il y avait mal en plus j'en ai
jamais mangé mais il y avait un marché
noir
et là c'était pour la bonne cause
puisque c'était pour nourrir son mari
qui était ce qui était dans la cave
oui mais il est il est consigné dans une
serviette figaro est marrant et 7 kg il
al'air considère avant le bon odile tu
n'étais pas bon et il va sûrement
tendance à me parler me chagrine de
témoin alors sur le pan du cinéma aussi
témoin moi j'ai porté l'étoile
j'étais tout petit j'ai porté l'étoile
j'avais l'âge limite j'apprends des tas
de choses jamais l'âge de mauriac
dimanche dernier bon alors ce que j'aime
moins dans le film de truffaut qui est
celui que je préfère avec la nuit
américaine je parle de ces dernières
années c'est justement ces deux partis
c'est le film et en même temps
extrêmement léger dans le sens aérien
très distrayante je lis avoir ce genre
de 9 et admirable depardieu est
formidable poiret aussi et puis de
l'autre côté
racontant l'occupation avec des détails
dérisoire qui moi m'ont complètement
bouleversé à savoir la peau femme qui
sort qui jouait par paulette dubost qui
est je ne sais plus je rentre c'est la
costumière du théâtre et qui sort des
tas de certificats de baptême et de
filiation pour vous prouver que son fils
n'a aucune goutte de sang juif
ce à quoi nous avons tous été forcé
pendant un certain nombre d'années même
tout petit je le répète également la
petite fille qui porte son étoile et
qu'on fait une petite fille qui est une
adolescente et qui dit moi je vais au
théâtre tout de même parce que je vais
mon écharpe par dessus et donc je ne
suis jamais prise en défaut
ce sont toutes ces petites touches qui
sont dérisoires dérisoire parce que ça
n'est pas dangereux parce que personne
ni mort d'avoir à porter l'étoile en la
cachant parce que personne n'est mort
d'avoir sorti des certificats de
filiation aryenne enfin je veux dire la
mort est venue plus tard et qu'on ne
voit pas de low cost mais on le sent
rodez sans arrêt rodez sans arrêt c'est
l'humiliation vertigineuse qui est
formidablement décrite tout en restant
un film parce qu'il se passe dans l'est
dans un théâtre et dans les coulisses
d'un ter qui reste un film d'une
légèreté mais complètement vaporeuse et
qui n'assiste jamais et c'est ça que je
trouve moi personnellement bouleversant
est admirable bon et puis aussi histoire
d'amour parce que ça c'était très
difficile à faire la naissance de la
naissance de l'amour entre autres
depardieu et c'est ça qui m'intéresse le
plus ce mois dans ce film c'est vrai
dire que bien sûr je ne peux pas parler
avec autant de d'émotion que qu'odile de
cette période
derrière de l'occupation poupas je n'ai
pas vécu du tout mais ce qui m'intéresse
le plus dans cette histoire c'est
justement le côté théâtral c'est je
crois que finalement ça n'est pas pour
rien que l'un des personnages joués par
le personnes par poiret merveilleusement
d'ailleurs et est une évocation à
m'at-il semblé de sacha guitry la
manière dont il
il est arrêté plusieurs fois en robe de
chambre on le voit sortir encadrés par
le seul genre plus c'est quelqu'un qui
était arrêté régulièrement et qu'on
relâche est parce qu on pouvait vous
pouvez rien gardé contre lui finalement
de sérieux je crois que c'est vraiment
une évocation sacha guitry et je crois
que ce film finalement est un peu une
manière d'envisager le théâtre comme
l'envisagé sacha guitry
parce que je vous crois me souvenir que
sacha guitry avait une une adoration
pour une pièce qui s'appelle s'il vous
plaît et d'ailleurs il tournait un film
qui s'appelle s'il vous plaît dans
lequel il est il avait ce qu'il l'est ce
qui l'intéressait c'était de montrer
dans la pièce qu'il y était question les
personnages disait si c'était au théâtre
et si nous étions au théâtre voilà
comment les choses se passeraient je
vous dirai ceci et je vous dirai cela
m'est donc jouets si vous voulez à se
mettre en scène et même sur la piste sur
la scène de guerre des camps se
chiffrait à fait le film il a fait se
passer dans une auto il a fait
exactement l'équivalent c'est à dire
qu'on voit envoyé guitry je crois que
jacqueline delubac qui disait voilà si
nous étions dans mon cinéma n'est ce pas
est devant nous serions dans une voiture
et voilà ce qu'on verrait et voilà il y
aurait un travelling avant qui
montrerait ceci et cela
et le film se pose pour super de cette
manière là bon je crois que finalement
truffaut finalement m'at-il semblé a
voulu pratiquer vis-à-vis du théâtre ce
cinéma que dans sa friterie du a donné
le dernier exemple c'est à dire que
finalement il ce jury se base sur le
rapport et la différence précisément
entre les personnages et ce qu'ils
interprètent sur le t elle sur la scène
du théâtre et alors il ya
perpétuellement un jeu
entre ce que se disent les personnages
ce qu'il ceux qui se font les regards
qu'il se jette et les mini qu'ils se
font que le public ne voit pas parce
qu'il se passe quand même sur scène un
certain nombre de libertés que le public
n'aperçoit pas et également ce qui se
passe en coulisses et qui est parfois
plus graves ce qui se passe bien entendu
sur la scène pour lui drame horrible on
est en train de visiter la cave enfin de
la situation ces fonds dont peut être et
on ne le sait pas parce que le spectacle
continue
je crois que c'est ça qui m'a passionné
le plus sûr écouter françois truffaut de
temps en temps je suis pas sûr d'avoir
été si raffiné que le décret et que la
description faite par robert benayoun ce
qui est vrai c'est j'ai fait évidemment
un contraste entre les personnages dans
la vie et dans le théâtre dans la vie
ils sont obligés de vivre dans le
compromis comme on vivait à ce moment là
ils sont dans le relatif jusqu'au cou je
dirais tandis que dans la pièce
évidemment il s'exprime avec lyrisme
avec force et probablement la pièce les
amène à prononcer des phrases d'amour ou
des phrases qui ne prononcerait pas dans
la vie réelle l'idée d'avoir pris une
pièce norvégienne il saignait n'est
forte
c'est très astucieux parce qu'il aurait
pu vous l'auriez vu leur faire jouer si
ce serait et 80 entend leur faire jouer
à pirandello premiers faits leona lewis
aurait été trop
non ça aurait été trop laissé la laddh
bonne idée justement c'est d'avoir une
pièce avec des répliques très très forte
alors que tout est feutrée mois gdt sûr
et je me suis fait complètement avoir et
je suis j'aime bien me faire avoir au
cinéma c'est agréable parce que je
n'avais pas prévu
le rapport amoureux depardieu deneuve
qui arrive tout doucement comme ça et
que qu'on découvre un peu gelé il arrive
comme ça on ne pense pas que ça va se
passer parce qu'on l'a détourné beaucoup
on a détourné et retardé rien fausses
pistes d'andrea ferréol qui est là elle
est dure même très loin mais ça c'est
très fin et alors c'en est d'autant plus
beau c'est contenu c'est sont quand même
les deux vedettes alors fatale gignac
qui vont changer suivant n'a rien dit
oui non moi j'aime bien le film tout de
suite je veux le dire j'étais parfois
très réticent sur des films de françois
truffaut
ce savoir et comment c'est vrai il sonné
je crois que malgré tout ça doit
l'étouffer sept ans en jeu dire je crois
que cette non non non
il a été acquis qui était un critique
féroce même ce chef-d'oeuvre du balance
comme ça au visage depuis dix jours doit
doit un peu la casse et parce que maman
papa lancé il est il qu'il a écrit
récemment il a dit il n'ya qu'un seul
critique à propos de l'amour en fuite
qui a écrit ce film est une escroquerie
il avait raison j'espère que dans deux
ans il va pas nous dire la même chose
sûre c'est sur ce film que je ne
considère pas du tout comme une escroqué
donc jamais pas beaucoup l'amour en
fuite ne win or j'aime pas ça te met
d'ailleurs s'être passionné bien sûr ce
n'est pas un escroc mais ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai beaucoup moi je me sens quand
on a tort de deux des films de truffaut
comme un réalisme ce qui me plaît le
mieux dans ces files leur essence et des
fines qui tourne autour du spectacle ou
de l'écriture ou du c'est à dire l'homme
qui aimait les femmes la nuit américaine
et est ce film ci qui melun sur
littérature l'autre sur le sur le cinéma
et celui ci sur le terrain est beaucoup
plus que l'occupation qui est très très
bien reconstituée j'ai pas du tout de
reproches à faire sur cette précaution
d'époque qu'on a loué c'est beaucoup
plus tous et tous ces rapports justement
cette très belle métaphore du metteur en
scène qui est qui est en bas est qui et
qui dirige comme les marionnettes tout
le monde
ces rapports justement de jouer cette
façon de truffaut le site valeur des
choses qu'on est amené à dire et qu'on
dirait peut-être pas dans la vie et ça
je crois que c'est très alors venez je
vais vous jouez vous choquer ou pas vous
avez le désir on dira que moi je pense
plus à quelqu'un que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup je pense plus à une tradition
et je ne veux pas faire plaisir aux gens
au sol mais l'attraction de rené clair
c'est que je crois qu'il ya un côté
ludique un côté très écrit dans votre
cinéma très admirablement joué dialoguer
photographier qui moi me fait penser
plus sa tradition de clair que par
exemple à hitchcock on cite souvent
votre vote rien
quel chemin faisant penser comment vous
jugez pour reprendre ce que des
échéances autonome vous avez été assez
serré gare de claira 25 ans et comment
vous pensé comment vous voyez clair
aujourd'hui j'ai pas beaucoup écrit sur
lui parce que je pense que c'est une
période où il n'a pas tourné beaucoup de
films mais non je crois que dans l'est
dans un film de rené clair on sait
vraiment où vont aller les personnages
est lui même le sait en commençant son
film plus que je le sais moi même je
crois c'est ça avance et que howie de
même le sens qui se dégage ne découvre
qu'après à travers ce que j'attendais
quand vous avez commencé quand vous avez
commencé
il est bien par exemple ils étaient bien
les dix dernières minutes n'existait pas
à vous voyez j'avais un moment
j'avais dans un scénario un char qui
sautait depardieu était dans le char la
division leclerc beaucoup et puis je me
suis dit non c'est disproportionné j'en
ai fait quand même un espèce de
résistants occasionnels de la dernière
heure c'est plutôt parce que son copain
copain avec un type qui prend plus de
risques lui progressivement
progressivement il se dit oui c'est ça a
progressivement ils veulent le rejoindre
il a un peu honte au début on voit qu'il
a une vocation théâtrale
il quitte le grand guignol qui est un
théâtre proche du théâtre forain il est
fier d'entrer dans un théâtre artistic
qui serait un peu comme la troupe
pitoeff et puis progressivement il se
dit non c'est quand même la résistance a
failli là il assista aussi l'arrestation
de son copain dans une église
donc la fin je les trouvais en tournant
au moment de tournage j'ai dit bonjour
j'ai trouvé un bon déjà c'est effrayant
mais vous avez tout parce que la fin il
doit résumer l'ensemble du film et
l'ensemble du film je le connais en
général que quand je suis au milieu du
tournage quand j'ai vu les réactions des
gens quand on vu de même que le texte
bouge il
il a l'air très écrits mais enfin il est
quelquefois écrit le dimanche pour les
jours qui vont venir
voilà ça bouge ça bouge il faut un
espèce d'équilibré donc c'est le
contraire de la technique rené clair il
lui a toujours tourné est plus préparé
prendre entièrement oui enfin le
tiraillement bien sûr qu'il ya un
tiraillement pour moi le tiraillement il
est que je n'aime pas les situations
molle et j'aime l'idée de progression
dans un spectacle je suis très attaché
c'est vrai mais en même temps il faut
que les situations soient forts sans que
les personnages deviennent des
marionnettes donc il faut aussi que les
personnages soient très vivant et
souvent ils sont vivants grâce à des
phrases qui ne veulent rien dire ou qui
ne font pas avancer l'histoire
alors c'est cette espèce d'équilibré on
essaie de maintenir qui continuent
d'ailleurs montage parce que montage ya
des petits sacrifices à faire surtout
quand on a six ou sept personnages on a
évidemment un peu plus de métrage que ce
dont on a besoin
donc là encore le film change de sens à
mon avis bout jusqu'au jour du mixage et
même au mixage en changeant une musique
de place on peut encore changer le sens
d'une scène grande lune plus solennelle
et l'autre voilà je crois oui j'en chie
en salle ce que viennent d'être ifo est
absolument passionnant
il nous éclaire sur ses méthodes de
travail je crois comme il n'a peut être
jamais fait dans un cas des interviews
qu'il a données
et moi je trouve ces déclarations tout à
fait passionnante alors je vais lui
poser une question sur une scène du
nous lorsque depardieu qui reproduit une
scène hot antic qui s'est passé pendant
l'occupation entre jean marc et alain
lowbrow agressent le critique
catherine sa partenaire marion la gueule
avec une très grande violence et tu dis
que tu risque de nous faire interdire la
pièce tu es le dernier des [ __ ] je ne
veux plus rien avoir à faire avec toi je
te parlerai plus jamais et c est ce que
l ne dans votre esprit c'est une
question que je vous pose comme suit à
ce que vous venez nous dire est ce que
dans votre esprit cette scène n'est pas
un rideau de fumée qu'elle élabore pour
occulter le sentiment qu'elle commence à
éprouver pour son partenaire on peut le
prendre comme ça la scène vous l'avez
admirablement décrite sauf qu'elle le
voit il n'y aurait jamais tutoiement le
vouvoie et elle mais on peut penser
aussi qu'elle est solide et a
complètement de son mari pour elle peu à
peu cette entrée dans sa tête aussi
qu'une seule chose compte c'est le
théâtre marque mais pourquoi elles nous
disent vous c'est le son côté directrice
de théâtre
pourquoi ya t'il se vouvoient mans est
là seulement tout fou raide un côté très
directrice de théâtre et je lui ai
demandé vous savez j'ai demandé j'ai
mûri j'ai voulu intéressant j'ai voulu
par exemple que le mari soit de 10 ans
plus âgé parce qu'il ya quelque chose de
productif en révèle son secret j'ai
demandé à depardieu de garder pas mal
d'éléments adolescents alors qu'il
aurait pu jouer par exemple beaucoup
plus mais je n'ai pas désiré qui joue à
dieu je voulais qu'il soit un peu moins
âgé qu'elle et elle je lui ai demandé
d'avoir 35 ans et de ne pas chercher à
paraître moins alors en sorte que la
patronne
il l'appelle madame stener jusqu'au bout
je te démarche je tenais beaucoup parce
que c'est du parc il l'appelle madame
stener que les scènes d'amour quand elle
arrive enfin je sais pourquoi je les
mets au pluriel d'ailleurs à peut-être
une certaine force
vous voyez c'est ça oui mais est
je reviens à ma question est ce que
c'était prémédité
est ce que dans votre esprit oui presque
jamais d'eau douce est parti puisque ces
parties de victoire de jean marais avec
le broc et que jean marais du moins
cette histoire qu'il racontait dans tous
les livres de spectacle mais j'ai
préféré la version jean marais je me
suis restée la plus authentique
jean marc est dit et son retour dans la
rue cocteau m'a engueulé il m'a dit à
cause de toiles théâtre on va être
arrêté quatre ans aux bourbons voilà oui
il fait beau alors bon mais alors la
question que vous vous posez tout à
l'heure et la suivante
il voulait ce que malgré tout et
j'aimerais que vous me disiez ici si oui
mais voilà c'est ce que je ne veux pas
je veux pas interpréter je voudrais
savoir si vous l'avez fait exprès aussi
ses loisirs à bec ou si elle a évolué si
elle a voulu mettre une barrière entre
elle et un homme qu'elle commence à
aimer parce qu'elle est tout de même
toujours très attaché à son mari ou
est-ce que la réagir directrice de
terrain je crois qu'elle est réellement
en colère à ce moment là qu'elle est
réellement en colère sur une chose qui
peut menacer et puis la grande colère de
collisions de neuf amène la réaction de
depardieu parce que s'il n'y a pas que
l'amour dans ce film il ya d'autres
choses beaucoup plus intéressantes et
plus importante c'est la réaction de
depardieu qui dit et puis il y en a
assez il n'y a pas que le théâtre et la
salle dans la pâte le théâtre qui son
plein en ce moment et aussi les prix ya
aussi les prisons et c'est ça qui est
beaucoup plus important dans toute la
seine c'est là la réponse de depardieu
je trouve aussi que truffaut à éviter
chaque fois que quelque chose se
préciser dans ce film j'avais une
trouille folle qu'il tombe dans des
pièges à savoir quand le mari de marion
stener qui joué formidablement par heinz
bennent se trouve dans la cave et quand
on sait que de gheest à peas vont
descendre dans la cave est que depardieu
aide le mari enfin stener à effacer les
traces de sa présence dans la cave
quand les deux guest star dans la cave
en son nom d'un chien on va voir quelque
chose réveillant une écharpe
oui oui il va y avoir un pied où il va y
avoir quelqu'un qui va éternuer pas du
tout légué stabies rien rien n'est
visible à éviter absolument tous les
pièges et quand aussi depardieu dans un
coup de colère dit à 4
1 marion stener alors qu'ils pourraient
le faire théâtre allemand où il pourrait
affecter une sorte de mystérieux et doux
secret à propos de la de la résistance
exil et puis merde et puis je faire de
la résistance
et c'est le côté malhabile du personnage
qui en fait une suprême habilité
j'aimerais vous poser une question un
peu parce que depuis que j'ai vu le film
j'ai posé à au moins dix personnes toute
cette semaine et je n'arrive pas à voir
et vous avez vous êtes documenté plus
que quiconque sûrement c'est un tout
petit moment où au moment où je t'ai
nerfs dit j'en ai assez d'être dans
cette cave j'en peux plus la zone libre
n'existe plus depuis quelques heures il
s'en fout il veut sortir
oui bon et catherine deneuve dit mais tu
es fou dit tu vas c'est épouvantable de
nuit tu veux tu vas te faire arrêter et
tu vas aller dans un camp de
concentration
oui et alors là je me suis dit tout d'un
coup j'étais pas bien vieux ans et vous
encore moins en 42 115 de 2,50
est-ce qu'il est vraisemblable qu'il y
ait au théâtre parisien
absolument je vais vous donner je vais
vous donnez moi un exemple je vous
donner deux exemples il ya évidemment to
be or not to be qui est tourné en 42 et
sur lequel vous avez une scène entière
qui tourne sur l'expression comme
concentration le général allemand à qui
on dit on les appelle contre les états
unis
ah bon on m'appelle comme concentration
toute la scène et là dessus et d'autre
part je retrouvais plus récemment
d'ailleurs enfin une citation de
saint-exupéry de 1938 38 ou 39 où il
parle de camps de concentration les
camps de concentration ils ont été
construits en 32 s'étaient connus d'un
certain nombre de gens ils n'étaient pas
connus en tant que camp d'extermination
bien sûr ni les chambres à gaz et tout
ça est le bailleur d'ailleurs je fais
comme moi je vis et même chaque
dictateur parle des cantons concernés
comme pour l'urss on connaissait les
vacances on ne savait pas on ne pouvait
pas savoir ce qu'était vraiment le mot
était déjà employé je vous ai fait
confiance à mal est ce que la directrice
s'attaquer à ses torts et parisiens même
épouse d'un metteur en scène juif qui a
quitté l'allemagne mais moi je suis sûr
mais max ophuls avait entendu parler des
concentrations sanguines même pour
l'urss on savait dès 37 y avait les
camps alors raison de plus pour
l'allemagne nazie qui était beaucoup
plus sur les appeler des camps de
travail non oui mais on fait avec
l'agent été liquidée on n'avait pas eu
ce patient est très bien c'est le bon
centre à 6 qu'on n'avait pas de projet
on avait beaucoup reproché à chaplin
justement d'avoir fait de ces camps de
concentration une espèce de dortoir tout
à fait anodin mais on ne pouvait pas
savoir à l'époque les documents ont
filmé c'est un collège de l'uby avait
atteint qu'en période de l'opposition me
fait signe dans la cabine que je dépasse
largement la question la plus banale qui
soit que vous pensez à quel film non a
je pense pas un film j'ai non non mon
seul un danger c'est d'aller voir la
semaine prochaine le film de raphaële
billetdoux à connaît pas vu encore voilà
ça vaille est très solide et très jolie
d'ailleurs oui odile j'ai voulu savoir
ce qu'il pense du fait qu'on le comte
site du tri renoir hitchcock à propos de
ses films ces derniers c'est normal de
citer je crois pas qu'un écrivain
romancier oublie qu'il y à flaubert et
stendhal les histoires de cinéma elle
fait 80 je pense que c'est normal enfin
ses metteurs en scène sont nos
classiques et il est logique de penser à
eux à tel ou tel moment de l'écriture de
scénarios du tournage tournage aussi ou
bien sûr exemple par exemple si vous ne
dites pas je sais quand on doit filmer
un objet par exemple la plupart dans la
plupart des films si si vous avez à la
fois le visage est l'objet personne ne
voit l'objet d'un kit scop nous a appris
que si on veut montrer l'objet il faut
des cadres et le visage décapité le visa
voyez donc à ce moment là c'est grâce à
escot cofra le cadrage correct c'est ça
c'est ça
renoir je suis passé davantage
l'impression de vie c'est davantage
l'impression quand on pense qu'une scène
donne une bonne impression mais qu'elle
est encore améliorable qu'elle peut être
un peu plus vivante si peut-être la voix
d'un personnage chevauche un autre
arrive mais ça arrive au fur à mesure au
fur et à mesure qu'on en a besoin mais
il arrive aussi des souvenirs personnels
qui vous aide aussi au moment où on en a
besoin et les comédiens et les comédiens
et catherine deneuve
et je trouve encore plus sublime que
d'habitude parce qu'elle a la froideur
enfin bon tout les clichés que l'on dise
aux derniers ne veut pas les éviter
parce que c'est on dit toujours la
froideur catherine sinon on dit le feu
sous la glace dit le feu sous la gare là
le cliché habituel soit 10,9 c'est ça
bien sûr mais c'est extraordinaire là
parce que on l'a jamais vu à ce point
froid de l'autorité autoritaire in
érable aussi vulnérable rentrant dans sa
chambre d'hôtel héroïque que pour cacher
tout la vie secrète que la nuit ça c'est
fantastique c'est à dire que même quand
elle joue un rôle simple a toujours
l'air double donc je me suis je veux lui
donner un rôle double pour lesquels vous
allez quoi dru série faut il rester
toujours un admirable critique ce qui
semble exactement
vous trouvez normal qu'elles sortent
tous qu'elle ne soit jamais libre de
soirée qu'on trouve ça que ça m'intrigue
pas des gens c'est une évidence a créé
bien c'est bien
[Musique]